the Kenyan president's right-hand man
has his work cut out for him NCO quwata
will be responsible for implementing any
bilateral agreements reached between
Kenya's president Uhuru Kenyatta and
German Chancellor Angela Merkel during
their meeting in Berlin the agenda
includes development trade and
cooperation to boost Kenya's potential
of interest is Kenya's role as a
regional peacemaker and the kind of
support we get from countries like
Germany in strengthening that role and
strengthening our ability to be an
honest broker within within the region
the two leaders are also expected to
discuss tourism investments and trade
but despite the positive outcome
anticipated some Kenyans in Nairobi
doubt the bilateral talks will have
little real impact there's no security
structure in Kenya so how can the
president implement security agreements
with no structures here
he should have sat with Kenyans and
solved the problems here because this
kind of travel is expensive
he needs to solve the problems here the
Kenyan government is keen to see an
increase in German investments in Kenya
more German tourists visiting the
country and a boost in Kenyan exports to
Germany the last year alone we've done
close to 110 million euros worth of
exports into Germany and about 450
million euros worth of imports from
Germany Kenya and Germany have enjoyed
warm relations since Kenya gained
independence in 1963 whitea says he
hopes those ties will deepen in the
years ahead